let's talk culture War we have this from
the New York Post Twitter to start
charging twenty dollars per month for
verification under new owner Elon Musk
are you gonna pay Tim yes oh Meister
money bags tell me more I've talked
about this a lot before I think that uh
verification should be literally for the
purpose of verifying users so you know
who I am so there's no impersonators so
that I can be like this is my official
account then Tim cast news will also buy
its verification and say this is the
official account of Tim cast news so
that you don't follow the wrong account
it's easily there for you and the other
thing people don't realize is it's going
to come with features and I think I I
just think it's ultimately good that
regular people can choose to sign up and
then you know you're talking to a real
person makes the platform way more
valuable in my opinion yeah you want to
you know put your money where your mouth
is and and right now Elon Musk and
Twitter are promising some some really
amazing things to combat a lot of the
nonsense that we're facing if if they
Backtrack on it if the government
defeats them if they don't if Elon
doesn't keep his promise I'm canceling
my 20 subscription that's another way to
vote with your dollar
um and and he also talked about uh you
know there's also rumors right now that
he might bring back Vine soon he tweeted
about that he's going to a lot of
cryptocurrency on the platform and allow
people to of course uh have end-to-end
encryption so he's promising a lot of
good things that that I think are
interesting so far he's he's doing
things that that I I think are good I I
I I I I can't really criticize him he
hasn't done everything I wanted him to
do but it's still early but I'm going to
be keeping an eye on here's the best
part
many of the woke Twitter Roddy these
journalists 10
000 followers five thousand twenty
thousand but they're verified meanwhile
there were people like James O'Keefe
they banned him and he had like a
million something and he was not
verified Julian Assange not verified for
these people it's the only thing that
makes them feel valuable or important
and Elon is gonna rip it right out of
their chests and I want to see it there
are people that they're like well you
know I have a verified Twitter account
with 5 000 followers and I'm like oh
yeah buddy so does my dog my dog's
verified these people build their
self-worth off of getting verified on
Twitter working for these big
institutions and being prestigious and
Elon Musk is going to kaliman rip it
right out from him and then I'm gonna
laugh the whole time because they stake
their value in a little stupid icon on a
social media platform ah thanks Elon I
went the other direction I am not
verified I have no interesting but I
will only become verified if they ask me
to become verified that's my goal with
Twitter well again you're a free person
you could do whatever you want and it's
going to be interesting because this is
a way to to fight against the pressure
that Elon Musk is facing from Bill Gates
The Washington Post and a lot of people
in The Establishment that are calling
for an Advertiser boycott now with this
new system yeah boycott all you want we
don't care we got people paying for for
the platform if they want to use it I'm
going to be paying for it I want to use
it especially if he keeps his promises
he does it I'm gonna boycott it that was
my plan up until Elon bought it was I'm
never going to ask to be verified if
they come to me and they're like okay
hey come give verified Ian I would do it
now this sounds like an upgrade of
Twitter blue so this is just basically
the paid version of Twitter I kind of
like it because if it offers a bunch of
cool features like editing longer tweets
things like that longer videos it might
just be worth paying the 20 bucks for in
that case I would maybe consider doing
it and if it comes with verification
then there's talk of longer videos right
um I do think though you know I guess
inversely Twitter needs to be paying its
top accounts for producing content or
just do some ad share or you know yeah
you just share some of that money you
could pay some percentage of the Twitter
blue income well or yeah right but based
on like how many views do your tweets
get or something like that it's always
tough because then people will make
inflammatory tweets maybe put legitimate
fake news for the purpose of generating
traffic
but that's YouTube right right so what
do you do oh yeah
yeah so would you police it or would you
just have you know just kind of a true
like referral you allow the advertisers
to advertise on who or what they want to
do if they're offended by someone you
just simply give them the choice like
okay I won't
your your content won't be shown with
this person's content he also Elon also
talked about having a platform where you
decide your experience so you could go
into a kid's version of of Twitter where
of course everyone cares about your
emotions everyone is there calling you
by your pronoun and your gender and then
an adult version where people could
actually have you know rational real
conversations that don't need to play by
certain rules a wild west and when you
do that you open kind of the pathway of
individuals to kind of determine their
own experience which I think is awesome
and great you could gamify the system I
built uh and then you can't say you
can't have a person complain like I I
can't I don't want to go on the kids
playground then if you don't want to be
in the adult section go and go into the
little playground pit here on mines I
built a gamification model for mines
where you would be basically get tokens
for using the site you could use these
tokens to buy or to hire avatars that
you'll send out on missions and then
every day you'll get a notification
throughout the day if you click the
notification it's like your hero found a
sword if you're there if you don't click
the notification he doesn't find it so
you'll be like it'll create generate
attention for the site and then when
they come back from their mission you
get a trophy that goes in your profile
so if you want to turn on gamification
mode is there a play and then that'd be
a good way to integrate utility tokens
well let me just invert invert that on
you is there a DND social media but you
can totally do that you could battle
against friends and use tokens to
empower abilities I would like like like
it's it's basically a social media
website but it's a DND game and then
dude you could augment react do
augmented DND Twitter like you could
look at your friend and like have a
turn-based at game it'd be so fun I'd
I'd probably sign up for something like
that it'd be wild and you could it could
be an overlay where you flip it on and
then just turn it back off if you don't
want it on or not I'm just saying like
literally I bet someone's gonna comment
saying it exists but I'm saying like oh
website where you create a profile you
friend people and your profile is also a
level leveling up character with
notifications that like you can engage
in scenarios and play games yeah that'd
be fun hell yeah that'd be a fun game
like
it's there's got to be something like
that I don't know the model's built so
if you want to implement it Elon let me
know we just didn't have enough
developers at mines to put it up it's
like a it's like a social media MMO yeah
you know yeah it's a good token sync
because the thing about utility tokens
and giving them out is you're making
them you need a way to to deflate the
currency so it's a good way for people
to put tokens back into the system right
kids version yeah what is it oh Russell
Brand gave your I word tweet props
yesterday on his YouTube segment
I just started tweeting words like none
of those broke the rules I was like I
said can I tweet naughty words now when
Elon bought when we finally closed the
deal as I started tweeting words that
aren't questionable like I guess for
Twitter's rules or something but it's
like you can basically tweet most words
without actually getting in trouble on
YouTube I mean I mean on Twitter
that's how most these platforms work
anyway have you seen more engagement in
the past week or so well I gained a
bunch of followers yeah I guess people
are trying to spike too I did as well
yep yeah without tweeting very much so
yeah yeah I just think
what happened with Twitter is that when
they realized journalists were using it
that was their that was their core user
base and started pandering to them is
their Echo chamber and that's how
stories are generated the reason so
Twitter talked about removing follower
counts retweet counts and uh and making
verification for everybody and they just
decided never not to do it and the
reason because the journalists like the
gamified retweet counts like bragging
about their follower accounts and they
like the fact the verification badge is
a status symbol that's granted to you
like Knighthood so they would never give
up on it I think if Elon Musk strips all
that away here's what I say Elon should
remove follower counts remove retweet
counts put all those analytics behind
the scenes you can find someone's
profile you don't know how many
followers they have you can follow them
if you want
you can see how many followers you have
the public doesn't see it you tweet
something out they can retweet it if
they want no one can see how many
retweets it has why why is the retweet
icon got a number on it
what's the point of that it's free the
user can use that number to inflate
their own value if they want to get you
can see it behind the scenes why is it
being you're right you could yeah you
don't need to be public it's not like I
saw your Tweet and need to know that it
was also a part of you know 10 000 other
accounts broadcast that makes no sense
it's a it's a it's a value symbol sure
the same thing with ratios
Twitter intentionally built the system
for the quote unquote ratio there's no
reason to show me a number of replies
right well and just show me the replies
unless you want drama unless you want to
see who got ratioed unless you want to
start controversy and and I think these
organizations have been doing that
deliberately they have been pushing I
think a divide and conquer agenda that
makes people hate each other and fight
each other based on trivial differences
that don't really matter in our lives
and I think at the end of the day it
wasn't an accident I think the FBI DHS
is like hey we got to make sure that
these people fight each other so they
don't really see what's really happening
to them and that's a perfect way of
doing that and now we have the proof the
government has been controlling the big
Tech social media companies so it's fair
to assert right now that they are the
ones pushing for ratios pushing for
hatred pushing for all the divisiveness
and all the drama that of course
captivates big Tech social media I just
hope you launched ready for the storm I
mean it's just beginning I mean they're
they're not going to let him just you
know purchase a piece of the cathedral
as you said the other day I mean that's
he he's got a piece of it now and
they're not they're not just going to
let that go quietly you can't hold it
it's like the one ring Elon need to
disperse it melt it into dust Elon knows
who Michael malice is he needs to call
up Michael and say let's talk Michael
needs to give start advising him on how
to deal with a lot of the stuff yes
decentralize the algorithm you want all
this stuff out of your own hands healing
you don't want to hold people's
passwords you don't want to hold
people's
names and addresses and and stuff like
that getting email email verification
keep it as as Baseline as possible and
get that stuff out uh like uh well I'll
go into more detail later I think he's
going to try and turn it into x.com
right he made X Holdings right to
acquire into PayPal he right he wants to
make it the one app for everything like
WeChat the American WeChat and that's
that's kind of scary if you think about
it it's I don't look there's a lot of
good things coming from Elon but I don't
I don't completely trust him he's got
business dealings in China
is this necessarily going to be a good
thing if we if if we end up using
Twitter think about how bad twitter is
with censorship and we're hoping Elon
fixes it it's still bad Viva fry got
suspended for tweeting about the Paul
Pelosi thing which is BS yeah imagine
you start using that for your payment
processing and for everything
and the censorship never gets fixed so
I'm not entirely confident it's like
he's in a position like George
Washington was After the Revolution
where he's the now he's the president
and they want him to become king people
will be like hey
just you be the one in charge don't do
it dude you got to give up the power
he's got a part in the political
prisoners he has to unban a lot of these
people but how is he going to deal with
the Department of Homeland Security
breathing down his neck being like no
you're not when so much of his
businesses are dependent on government
contracts
yep so SpaceX especially yeah this is
you know they're going to come after
them they're going to punish them sure
all the satellites that they're building
you know sure all the tech that they're
building his kind of dalliance with
transhumanism is is concerning as well
you know in your link and you know his
business in China it's it's it's it's
not a you know it's not a good guy be
skeptical of everyone obviously but when
it comes to the Battle of ideas he is he
is proposing Amazing Ideas important
ideas that no one else is and they're
crucially important for our uh existence
right now I agree so his battles against
Bill Gates his battles against
depopulation his battles against you
know the the real things that are coming
and are going to be hurting Humanity I
think are important and you know I'm
still not 100 convinced I'm still
skeptical of them but I think so far
he's one of the best things we have
right now when it comes to ensuring
freedom of speech no a human has that
can handle that responsibility though
you need to disperse the wrong about
you're right it should be an automated
system like like a Department of
Homeland Security right like a big
federal government that knows you know
government bureaucrats sitting in
offices deciding what people you know
can and cannot do right no no no system
where everybody holds their own private
keys and can log in with their own
private data and log out and no there's
no Central
um repository of data that the DHS can
go after you just say because I can't
give you the info because I don't have
it I never did that's the point if you
have it they will come and take it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there